during the first day of Judge Katanga Brown
Jackson's confirmation hearings. And by the first
day, I mean, Monday, the former President Donald
Trump attempted to do some counter-programming,
wherein he gave an interview to FOX Business host
Stuart Varney. And this was a very dangerous and
corrosive interview, and we're going to look at
a couple of clips of it. And there is one segment
here where Donald Trump provocatively wants to
talk about the N-word, but it's not the N-word you
think of. He's talking about nuclear or nuclear,
depending on your preferred pronunciation. Here is
Donald Trump talking about Putin and nuclear
Speaker 4: power and hope to God. You never
have to use that because it would be. That
would be the tragedy of all tragedies. But
if we didn't have it, we couldn't talk. But
I listen to him constantly using the N-word.
That's the N-word. And he's constantly using
it. The nuclear word. Right. And we never
talk it. We say, Oh, he's a nuclear power.
Speaker 1: So Trump there. I don't know if he
thinks it's clever or what to refer to nuclear
as the N-word, but Stuart Varney is visibly
perplexed by it. Then Stuart Varney made a big
mistake. Stuart Varney tried asking Donald Trump
about policy. And as you know and as I know
and as many of our viewers know, when you ask
Trump about policy, you do not get an answer.
It's almost satirical at this point to watch.
Speaker 2: There's this discussion about whether
we should send jets MiG jets to help the Ukrainian
Air Force. Would you send in that kind of help?
Speaker 4: Well, maybe even more, to be honest
with you. And I'm like, Mr. President, I
am the one that would have stayed out. Let
me just explain that Putin is saying things like,
Don't you dare send anything in? In the meantime,
he's killing thousands of thousands of people, so
he's acting like we're an aggressor if we send in
Sebold, forty four year old plane that probably
get shot out of the sky pretty quickly. And he's
acting like we're we're terrible people if we do
that. But he's killing tens of thousands of people
far more than they're reporting. You don't knock
down those buildings and blow up those buildings,
and they say two people were injured slightly.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So the question was,
would you send in the jets? And
Trump says, I might even send more.
And then the question is, well, what exactly
would you send and Trump's off on a tangent?
He later is able Varney is able to get Trump back
on track. And then there's the question of, Well,
OK, what exactly would you do? And Trump says,
Well, I might send nuclear subs to intimidate.
Speaker 4: Nobody knows where they are. And you
should say, Look, you mention that word one more
time. We're going to send them over and we'll be
coasting back and forth up and down your coast.
You can't let this tragedy continue. You can't
let us use these thousands of people die. It's
going to be hundreds of thousands and maybe
millions of people by the time it ends. Right?
Speaker 1: So I guess Trump is at the same time
that he has been very hesitant to criticize
Vladimir Putin and at the same time that he
delayed sending military aid to Ukraine because
he wanted dirt on Biden. He's also saying
he would be more aggressive than Joe Biden.
But at the same time, saying he would have
kept us out of war. So as you can tell,
this is what we might call in the academic
world a very complicated text. If you would
keep us out of wars, why would you be be be doing
more aggression than Joe Biden? It's all sort of
confusing. Later, the topic goes, and this is a
very dangerous topic for the former president.
Climate change and Varney asks a very specific
question, and Trump gives a very bizarre answer.
Speaker 4: What about climate change that
I don't even think ever took a course in
the environment? Is the climate change the
Speaker 2: climate changing because of human
activity?
Speaker 4:
In my opinion, you have a thing called weather and
you go up and you go down. If you look into the
1920s, they were talking about a global freezing,
OK? In other words, the globe was going to freeze,
and then they go global warming. Then they
couldn't use that because the temperatures were
actually quite cool and many different things.
So now they just talk about climate change.
The climate is always been changing.
Speaker 1: OK, so and as we know,
Donald Trump is one of the foremost authorities on
climate and as well as on renewable energy, right?
I mean, you guys remember his expertize there.
Speaker 2: The noise causes cancer.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So lastly, in this, just
a very it was a sort of a like a subdued,
low energy Trump. He almost sounded
slightly ill. Maybe he had just woken up.
Varney asks Trump what should be the case?
Let me see how I can. Even Trump says the focus
for Republicans in 2022 and 2024 should be how Joe
Biden still stole the election from him in 2020.
Speaker 2: If we go into 2020 to the elections,
we by the way, 2024, and you're still looking back
to the election of 2020 and saying that you really
won. I don't think that's very good
for you or the Republican Party.
Speaker 1: It's not a comment on that.
Speaker 4: Well, yeah, I actually think
it is good for me. And I think if we don't
put out all of the crooked things that we
know what they are, that you won't win
in 22 and you won't win in twenty four.
Speaker 1: I think what Trump means is
if if we don't keep talking about that,
people will forget about me.
Speaker 4: We don't get to it.
So I think it's the opposite, actually. And I
talk nothing about it. Nobody talks about you.
Speaker 2: But 20 22 after you think that twenty
twenty two and twenty twenty four are all about
the 2020 election, right?
Speaker 4: No, no, no. I think for us to
win the election, we have to know how they cheated
because otherwise they'll cheat again and we do
know how they cheated, OK, and the Republicans.
Speaker 1: But so then why do you need to talk
about it, right? I mean, it doesn't make any
sense what this is. This is really just it
needs to be about me for the next three years.
Speaker 4: And Democrats should, but they won't.
Republicans have to do something about it
or they're going to be very disappointed
and nobody talks more about the future than I
do. But you have to learn from history also,
and you can't let it happen again. So right,
Speaker 1: right? That would be a real shame,
as Donald Trump likes to say so a very
strange interview and sort of an attempt at
counterprogramming. The confirmation hearings
of Judge Catanese Brown Jackson. There it is.
We'll have the clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show,
and I'll have more information for you about
upcoming events that will be covering very soon.